president of the united states
this was president biden's first
official state of the union
[Applause]
the president did not wear a mask the
mood was definitely very different from
the last joint
address the just came at a critical time
in his presidency because the president
is still dealing with the economic
uncertainty that's resulted from the
pandemic and then of course he has a war
in europe to deal with so president
biden had very strong words for putin's
actions against ukraine putin's latest
attack on ukraine
was premeditated
and totally unprovoked
he rejected repeated repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato wouldn't
respond but putin was wrong
we are ready
he said russia would be more isolated
than ever before we're cutting off
russia's largest banks in the
international financial system he said
the u.s would uh close the american air
space to all russian air flights and
then go after russian oligarchs seas
their yachts their luxury apartments
their private jets as he was talking
about these measures we saw bipartisan
groups of lawmakers stand up to applaud
i'm taking robust action to make sure
the pain of our sanctions is targeted at
russian economy
and that we use every tool at our
disposal to protect american businesses
and consumers he announced one new
measure in his speech the u.s in
addition to 30 other countries would be
releasing 60 million barrels of oil from
reserves around the world these steps
will help blunt gas prices here at home
i want you to know
we're going to be okay the president
also spent a significant amount of time
in his speech talking about inflation
which is at a four decade high so the
president bringing up boosting domestic
production make more cars and
semiconductors in america
more infrastructure and innovation in
america this was one of the the ways he
said the us could sort of take more
control of the economy coming out of the
pandemic
there's been divisions related to the
pandemic
whether it's masking or vaccinations but
he tried to bring the country together
and say it was time to sort of move past
all of that